vous débutez aux échecs vous en avez
marre que vos adversaires vous prennent
pour un mouton en tentant contre vous le
célèbre coup du berger caractérisé par
cette sortie d'AM précoce pas de
problème je vous montre comment réagir
au mieux avec les noirs et prendre le
dessus ici on va jouer cavalier C6 le
coup naturel pour défendre notre pion E5
et là quand les blancs tentent de vous
mat en seulement trois coups vous leur
dites nietet en jouant G6 on attaque la
dame elle recule en F3 on crée une
nouvelle menace de ma et là on sort le
deuxème cavalier c'est facile à retenir
pour bloquer la colonne F les blancs de
la suite dans les idé dame B3 vientnent
rattaquer votre point faible pas de
problème on sort Notre Dame on vient le
défendre maintenant on attaque aussi E4
et après D3 pour défendre le pion il est
temps de donner un premier coup de bâton
au berger avec cavalier des4 et cette
dame va se retrouver très mal placée on
va ensuite simplement développer notre
fou et si on fait le bilan on a quatre
pièces de sortie contre seulement deux
et une bien meilleure harmonie de nos
pièces